[Music]
my name is Karla merace my name is
Brandon Roy we are the founders of
Roberta's and Brooklyn probably like
most kids I like loved pizza and after
every a great
accolade in school after everything you
got pizza and you went to the pizza
parlor and like your friends were there
so I just have this great affinity love
for for pizza and the places that pizza
came out of
there's the lure about the fire too and
it's why the oven is right out and the
open for everyone to see it there's just
still you walk by and you see a flame
and it draws you in
so the famous originals are kind of ode
to New York style pizza slice we have a
commissary kitchen where we make all of
our dough sauce and cheese the evolution
of the dough has been going on since day
one here we like to think that it's like
constantly getting better and better we
use very high grade flour especially a
blend of two different flours so we let
ferment for about two days kind of in
typical pizza making fashion the balls
come out they get lapped out into the
into the circle and then they get
chopped
so it's sauce chili flake regon Oh
Patrick Cavallo and
the wood-burning ovens you can get them
to a much higher temperature which is
really good for the pizza making just
keeping the oven at the right
temperature is probably the hardest
thing you're not just the cook at this
point where you're cooking a food you're
also like a Boy Scout you're maintaining
a fire it's a really clean burn so you
get a lot of flavors of the actual oak
that we use once you get the peel
underneath the pizza you can kind of
start to tell like how does this thing
feel as the weight of it right is that
is the bend of it right you know is that
cheese properly melted and as the bottom
done and the top done and that is it the
right color it goes from like a light
color to start blondie and then you
start getting the leopardy which is like
the charring doming is a really really
really important part of the process as
well where you're lifting the pizza up
right to the gel for the oven where it's
so the heat is circulating and capping
once you're at a point where you can
dome you have a really good
understanding from where the pies at how
much longer you need to relieve
the pizzas usually take around 90
seconds
I grew up along Allen so I was sort of
surrounded by you know that
italian-american style you know pizza
place pasta place and what we wanted to
try and do here was sort of create that
environment where everyone was welcome
from all walks of life it was sort of a
place that anyone could come
you know we're open throughout the day
from 11:00 a.m. until midnight seven
days a week 365 days a year you know
that was always our intention here was
to have a really really solid
well-crafted well-made food but also to
like bring a community together bring
people together and have a good time
[Music]
[Music]